[Musique]
le moment les chéris on va passer
aujourd'hui il n'y a qu'un coup de
gueule et c'est un coup de gueule de mon
ami benjamin castaldi c'est parti coup
de gueule sur ces inconvénients jingle
well as un coup de gueule c'est pas pour
départ de capucine bas au cameroun
capucine on l'a appris on n'a pas tout
vous dire que mon âme lui aurait appris
tout à l'heure moi je n'ai appris ce
matin on s'est vus ouais j'ai été
excellent dans la voiture et je crois
que céline a appris via un communiqué de
presse
c'est vrai que j'avais pas qu'elle ait
l'air l'annoncé c'est vrai alors j'ai
moi j'ai un vrai problème c'est que ça
fait un moment que dans cette édition
qui est une mission médias j'ai un peu
de mal à comprendre pourquoi on revient
pas donné le scoop à l'émission médias
oui c'est vrai je me suis assez d'accord
après je trouve ça très moyen mais
visiblement et apparemment c'est une
tendance actuelle c'est que je trouve ça
très bonne pas annoncé en premier à la
période groupe est beau c'est qu'on s'en
va il consomme a défini trois enfants
sont nés paris dans la benne qu'on va
l'annoncer sur les paris on va
l'annoncer ça c'est un problème est que
ça va c'est vrai que honnêtement mais
bon moi je le regrette parce que tu as
largement ta place dans ce but survient
alors elle trouve qu'elle est elle
trouve qu'elle et voilà on va on va pas
se mentir
capucine vous trouvez pas au niveau des
autres chroniqueurs ce qu'on m'avait dit
qu avait alors déjà si j'ai tenu à
l'annoncer c'est parce que peut-être que
vous vous allez pas être attristée par
moi ça m'attriste mais nous ça et je
serai les pmp signer mission d'humeur
j'avais pas envie de pleurer en temps
des fleury pas
et evreux maman
merci pour tout ce que tu veux sur toi
tu es quelqu'un qui laisse la chance aux
jeunes et un coeur énorme
j'ai passé une super année à tes côtés
et avec vous alors mason
et c'est vrai que tu as pu
pour tout vous raconter au cv ya deux
semaines dans mon bureau on a défilé
qu'ont d'ailleurs faire des choses
ensemble
voilà ce qu'elle m'a demandé et que
j'adore capucine qui est une afrique et
qui est vraiment c'est un amour 2 voilà
c'est vraiment quelqu'un donne un
meilleur sur la main c'est un ami je
l'adoré lors desquelles elle me fait
rire et voilà et c'est vrai que ici
voilà elle dit déchets du mal à trouver
ma place c'est vrai qu'elle vous trouve
elle vous trouve trop fort je vous dis
la vérité donc elle c'est vrai c'est ce
que tu m'as dit elle nettoie le trouve
voilà que vous êtes à la tête c'est plus
dur pour elle dans touche pas à mon
poste que dont ils en pensent quoi
qu'amélie javel angoisse avant chaque
émission j'avais envie de faire bien et
voilà et c'est vrai que montréal depuis
gamine c'est aussi un peu de faire la
comédie j'ai eu des propositions
extraordinaire pour la rentrée et voilà
et j'avais envie de faire un choix et
c'est vrai que c'est le rôle entre
guillemets parce que c'est pas un rôle
je m'amuse beaucoup mais je pense que
j'ai d'autres d'autres ont monté des
conneries en fait j'ai envie de me
prouver à moi même que je peux faire
autre chose que j'avais envie
d'apprendre aussi j'ai envie d'apprendre
j'ai envie de découvrir plein de choses
et je trouve que très jeune c'est bien
et vous avez fait une très belle saison
avec nous et j'avais envie de la finir
quand je commence quelque j'ai envie de
finir c'est pour ça que je veux finir la
saison avec vous aimez l'agencé la
dernière semaine exactement et vous
finirez la saison avec moi d'ailleurs
vendredi
et si vous voulez revenir vous êtes la
bienvenue aux dames ont invité vous
viendra chaque fois pour nous présenter
ce que vous allez faire et capucine moi
je voudrais dire c'était un bonheur de
l'avoir à manger l'adorent
oui à la rhubarbe du regard extérieur
oui ouais c'est ça que je voulais dire
tu mérites ta place autant tout le monde
puisque chacun une porte sur la vérité
et sert en gagnant ses deux matchs par
je respecte tout le monde mais à qui
john vraiment qui rend mais je pense que
je suis un peu trop jeune et ya
certaines choses que j'ai un peu plus de
mal alors que oui et voilà et je trouve
qu'un ans et bien en fait je pense que
subit moins appris plein de choses j'ai
amené tout ce que j'avais apportées dans
cette émission c'est vrai que nous avons
même des pizzas et je pense que j'ai
fait mon temps et quand vous savez qu'on
vous aime très fort et ma maman c'est
sincère et vous revenez quand vous
voulez mais très vite d'accord pour
faire de ce monde et jules verdez
capucine c'est une erreur je trouve ccni
interview que je trouve précipité je
trouve qu'elle aurait dû rester un an de
plus non mais alors il remplit d'accord
on s'est mis d'accord tous les deux
aussi parce que nous aussi on va voilà
on va on va avoir beaucoup nous avons
journalistes autour de la table l'année
prochaine aussi
avec bien sûr des deux animateurs aussi
qu'ils vont nous rejoint et c'est vrai
que capucine aussi dans cette nouvelle
formule voilà qui sera toujours autour
des médias où ça va déconner toujours
elle se sentait moins à l'aise on le
voit la cantine et des coups de gueule
et où j'ai toujours un petit peu mal de
mal à m'exprimer parce que j'ai peur
d'être jugé par des programmeurs ces
connards mais non mais n'ayez pas peur
en tout cas pour la suite et je suis sûr
que vous allez aux rabais est vraiment
on vous aime on vous aidera toujours
évincé gevrey était un bonheur de la
côtoyer pendant un an français pour moi
je le dis je suis assez sévère sur mes
rivaux legs mais c'est le sait le fils
de fernand vers des mois je suis moi je
te suis toujours la cote mal taillée
donc je me dis pourquoi pas quand même
une fois par semaine est ce que tu dis
sur la cohérence de ce que tu dis c'est
pas vrai d'ailleurs chaque fois que tu a
exprimé son opinion sur des choses
c'était toujours c'était toujours
cohérent ouais donc moi je feins moi
personnellement je regrette je regrette
beaucoup
et ben non fiscales alors après veulent
enlever rapt qui viendra nous voir une
fois par saba bien sûr j'espère que
j'aurai venir vous dire un peu mes
projets tout ça vous réussissez gratuit
sauf bien entendu
c'est vraiment plus merci capitaine
tincu ce vendredi au plus tard et qu'on
aime fort vraiment vainqueur très bon
allez